case I had a little message for you I'm
gonna plate for you now you're an idiot
yeah that's it idiot your rebuttal that
was his message to me what you want a
rebuttal I'll give you an hour but oh
you're an idiot you're warming up
already aren't you huh just trying to
wake up bro I'm not really a morning
person I know it's not the morning but a
slow start to the day
good thing the boxing matches that night
right honestly yeah no I swear I'm a
night owl so like 7:00 p.m. a p.m. like
trust I'll be awake Logan Paul just a
couple of days from the big rematch I
mean how you feeling oh there any nerves
uh not yet um I think it'd be a little
inhuman if I didn't feel some sort of
butterflies before but like now it's
just um it's a calm confidence man I am
a different fighter than I was last year
and I'm not I'm not really guessing
anymore I'm going in there knowing I can
do some serious damage
and unfortunately chaos I was gonna feel
that I feel that but it's also because
you also been preparing for the past
year I mean I know you've been putting
in the work you look yoked out you know
I thank you man yeah I just got this
brand-new six-pack I mean I sure never
have six-packs prove it like I'm so
proud of myself
in case you didn't believe him he's been
putting in work okay yeah yeah yeah no
it's brand-new so I feel great well I
got to tell you we talked to ksi
yesterday he's got Conor McGregor's
nutritionist and of course Floyd
Mayweather behind him what's your secret
weapon I saw that um I don't think it's
much of a secret I think everyone knows
it's Shannon Briggs Shannon the candid
Briggs I mean Conor McGregor's
nutritionist can cook as much food as he
wants but he ain't gonna these case I
had a box I got the two-time heavyweight
champ of the world just making me
download 35 years of boxing experience
so yeah chef one of the best boxers in
the world I don't know it's a bit of a
difference there you decide or you will
find out on Saturday right well listen I
know that uh you know before the first
fight case I reportedly said that he was
using you for clown you know did you I
mean did you feel that and they like why
why get back in the ring with him yeah
for sure so it's to me this is a very
mutual trade-off like the narrative for
the first fight was chaos I saved my
career and in you know
I don't know if that's true a hundred
percent but there's like some merit in
that like he definitely helped me come
out of the the trench I was in post
Tokyo and in exchange ya ksi has now
become like a global name the three
letters KS and I like no one really
knows they mean or like maybe who the
guy is like named a face situation but I
definitely made made him relevant
outside of the UK because before that I
don't I don't think if you lived outside
of the UK you knew who he was it's
interesting you say that because you say
you start his career and he told us I
made his career outside of the UK
outside of the UK I let's clarify that
outside the UK you kind of take
ownership over that but it's interesting
because he told us that he thinks after
the fight it's gonna be a total knockout
and then he's gonna quote end your
career how do you think this fight is
gonna end yes so he's right there will
be a total knockout and as far as ending
a career yo I think it's very obvious if
my career was gonna end it would have
happened already
I'm so sorry the window has passed I
want to talk about your brother real
quick because he posted this lengthy
Instagram I was kind of amazing cuz he
wasn't just gassing you up he really was
saying that this fight is a is a moment
bigger than you do you feel like you
have something to prove in the ring on
Saturday not just for you but also your
brother absolutely I mean our name
because of ourselves has been riddled
with you know X Y & Z negatively mostly
and so this is a challenge like you said
mainly for me to overcome ksi just
happens to be the person in the ring but
also to put some respect on our family
name because you know we've done some
dumb [ __ ] we've also done a lot of good
[ __ ] and I think if we can shift the
narrative and get the haters to cool off
a little bit and join the team this will
be a good start for that kind of why you
did the first fight to begin with
wouldn't you say you know kind of
shifted a little about how people view
you it was more of uh it was yes but I
I'll say it was more for me like for
selfish reasons I like took the fight
because I knew boxing would would change
me like hitting people and getting hit
in the face every day and working hard
and working on your body it changes who
you are and last year I was just down to
stuff like that you like again post
Tokyo I was like I needed something in
my life to change and boxing was that
outlet for me were you surprised by how
big of an impact that made on you no pun
intended there stunned stunned I I it's
so crazy because you see all the movies
all the boxing like movies how they're
hella inspirational motivational and you
after you watch Rocky you want to go run
50 miles in like doing that in real life
there is a massive impact it changed the
psyche of Who I am it's literally change
the the future of Logan Paul and for
that yeah I'm credibly grateful do you
think you'll ever go pro I know ksi has
said he wants to go pro man I got two
worst news bro we're all ready bro
boxers maybe like a bigger opponent
outside of chaos ah yeah for sure my
logic is like stroking my ego for a sec
I've I believe I've gotten too good at
this sport to not do something with this
skill set like like you're a human she's
a human he's a human anyone does
anything for a year and a half straight
you're gonna get pretty good at it I've
been doing this for a year and a half
straight you know why not why not
continue down the path you're continuing
down the path your brother kind of
looted to the fact that he wants to get
in the ring with ksi do you think
that'll ever happen yeah I do please
give it to it
I don't think chaos I'll take the fight
really I don't think so because I'm
gonna be ksi can you imagine if he takes
the fight against Jake and and loses
that too
I mean yo it's not gonna look good
that's I mean talk about career-ending
like goodbye forever good riddance I
will win this fight this weekend and the
internet will want JJ to fight Jake I
think KS I'll be too scared we'll say if
you win that's a good storyline taking
on the brother you know absolutely and I
mean Jake's really really really good
Jake's really good he's knocked down two
different sparring partners you the
other day like and this is this occurs
regularly he's ready now yeah he's ready
he's ready he's been with me the whole
camp if if Jo Markowski from the zone
gets him a fight maybe on December 20th
look they're ready writing checks right
now as we speak you know so we obviously
can expect your brother there on
Saturday who else is on the squad I hear
Justin Bieber by me making an appearance
on me yeah can you tell us will jb be
there yeah he'll be there yeah what are
the chances you'll walk out to a Justin
Bieber song zero only only cuz I already
picked my song what is it it's uh should
I say why not do it it's um it's the
opening to the purge you know when
they're like all crime including murder
is legal all weapons really and then it
goes wah wah so like I'm just trying to
terrify everyone in the stadium
[Music]